I mean a lot of what you're doing now is
with the anti-trafficking and and and
with the the the recovery out of
disaster hit areas is there a bit of is
there a bit of tactical or or um
physical or logistical retraining or is
it all values and if it is the values
I'd love to i' love to know what those
values are so I think I think what's uh
the main thing is we're instead of like
Mission focused and you know where's the
enemy protect protect the team sure all
that it's we're more humanitarian Focus
now right so you got to start working on
the interpersonal skills the empathy
really understanding what's going on and
and the uh the impact of your actions
and when you're out into in those
locations what you're really doing
because your our Focus now is a civilian
populace it's it's not it's not the
military side of things um and I think
the biggest disconnect and you probably
hear this theme a lot is like like
you're like lack of identity when you
get out of the service and some people
retire like myself but you have people
that are medically retired
maybe they you know have a substance
abuse issue or something they get
separated from the military whatever it
is um they end up getting taken away
from that life that they know so well
and they get put in the civilian world
right and and I say they but you know
it's me as well because I was like heal
heal the hero veteran number one right
my wife always says I'm like kind the
guinea pig yeah but uh I was there too
man like I have all this training I got
millions of dollars of government
training in me from you know from
everything from all these like Secret
Squirrel tools and you know all these
things man and when I got to that point
where I was getting out of the military
I was like what am I like all this is
useless now like what what am I going to
do now you know and I know athletes kind
of go through that a lot of these people
that are very uh they're known for one
thing you you kind of think like you're
useless out there and a lot of us would
be more comfortable like running in to a
firefight or being caught in an near
Ambush than like going out and figuring
out exactly how you got to start a
business or get your taxes done or you
know like it's it's so interesting that
it it's the it's the unknown right like
you get comfortable even with real
difficult dangerous life threatening
situations and being in the regular
civilian world is it's it's foreign and
it's almost kind of scary for for vets
which is super interesting so a lot of
our training is that it's like you know
your we have this tournament it's called
permanent change of station of PCS
permanent change of station yeah right
so like say I'm at I was in Germany
right and I got orders to go to a new
unit you get your PCS orders permanent
change of station so I try to tell these
vets man I'm like you're not like you're
pcsing from military pcsing the rest of
your life you know and you're taking all
those skills like everything you learned
and all that experience and now you're
going on to the next thing we got to
focus on what we got to do now we got
all these great things like let's go
figure out what we can do and and the
good we can do in now and in the future
and that's like our our main thing is
just so so putting that sort of feeling
of of purposeless of feeling lost the
fear putting that into service that
saved you in a way and that's that's
saving these guys and and and and can
you like how how did you how did you
come to that like where did that where
did that impulse come from how did you
figure that out yeah well you know I I
like to tell there's a couple stories
that really come to mind and and uh you
know throughout my career I always had
this I I think it drew me to the
military in the first place is like this
protective Instinct and and I have a
younger sister and through various
things that happened through my
childhood I was always very protective
of her and that transferred to who I am
and what I am as an adult and going out
and these deployments you know I've been
overseas like seven times about five
years of my life in combat zones and no
matter what the mission was like I'd
always see this stuff that was going on
on the outside I'd see these people that
are struggling or the the civilian
population that's affected by us being
there or or whatever is going on but
that's not my mission right my mission
is is is this my mission is assigned to
me and uh and that kind of bothered me
but I you know I'd always see that and I
remember a couple times like this one
time I was out in Iraq man and um this
is right outside solder City and you
were just doing a patrol like normal
Patrol and I'm sitting there on point
and I go down and I take a knee at like
the end of this intersection and the
cool thing you know about the military
right everything's assigned and you
train right you know so I got my sectors
of fire I got my 12:00 to my 9:00 this
is like this is what I'm responsible for
here like right like right here and so
I'm sitting down there I take a knee and
I'm skinning and I'm looking and I I
look like right to this little this
house next to me and there's like this
fence that goes around and a gate and
I'm looking at this gate and there's
like a you know like a rope attached to
and I follow this rope down and it's
attached to like this ankle right and I
and I follow it forward and it's like
this it's like this kid like an
11-year-old and I take a look at him and
he's tied up like a dog and I can't even
make his face out because he's covered
in flies and he was you know he was so
physically and and mentally disabled
that he didn't even have the wherewithal
the wipe his face and his parents had
just tied him up like an animal and put
food and water in front of
him and I you know I remember looking at
that and I'm like we got to do something
for this kid you know so I call it up on
my radio and my squad leader gets over
and he comes down and takes a knee he's
like what you got luck you know looking
over my shoulder looking for the bad
guys or whatever and I'm like look at
this kid like we got to do something
about this kid he like that's not here
that's not our job you know and and then
that was something that always stuck
with me and in the culture in the
military you got you have to almost hide
those feelings because you get ridiculed
for it so I I was made fun of for like
weeks or a month over in in Iraq because
I cared about this kid you know and that
that's something that you got to hold on
to that stuff man like because that's
that's your Humanity that's there you're
you're like you're in a war zone you're
seen all this crap and like your
humanity is still there so those are the
those are the point of references I want
to keep like talking to to our veterans
about is like let's focus on man there
there's goodness in every sort of
situation what can we do for those those
people and that's what we're trying to
do now is we're trying to use our skills
to help those people like like that poor
kid in in Iraq that was tied up how
common is it that you think that guys
especially in the SF Community have
stories like that right that you've had
to shut down oh yeah that because well I
mean and look at times I mean there's
stories of it you you start to have
empathy for somebody you start to and
that that takes you off the mission it
puts you at danger it puts the people
around you at danger but would you
imagine pretty much all these guys have
had things like that where their heart
has sort of bursted wide open for
somebody with with a case of empathy and
then they've had to shut it down oh yeah
yeah and you know the the military is so
interesting too because they they teach
you to kind of redirect that right so if
I see this like well that's those people
that are out here you know that's look
at what they're doing that's a result of
like the enemy and all of that so now
I'm looking at now I'm pissed off about
this and it's just fuel for me to get
revenge or fight harder or something
like that and I tell that about like
that's kind of like bad energy right um
and that that's something that they
really teach us but yeah man like you
see that stuff you see it everywhere and
and I'll be honest with you I think I
think the military is getting a little
bit better about it uh when I first was
in you know the early 2000s like you
didn't talk about mental health you
didn't talk about that's like quitting
on your team because you know it's like
it's a fake injury you can't there's
nothing wrong with you you know get your
ass back out there you just don't want
to deploy you're scared you're chicken
and that was a thing you know you go to
mental health that's it like you're a
coward y um I think we're starting to
understand that there's a reason you
know you have every 80 every 83 seconds
a US veteran commits suicide 83 seconds
man that's insane yeah and that those
are those scars like they're they're in
you those that's damaging man and and
that's kind of where it transitions
because there's there's so much broken
about like I know like the VA and I I
know they they want to they try to do
good things for you but there's so much
broken about it and uh and that's where
where we are now is because I was I
myself was a product of that and um I'll
just briefly go over this but in 20
December
2020 um I had gotten back from I'd
gotten back from Iraq or sorry Syria
that July that was my third trip out to
Syria and um and i' had met my wife
previous to that gone and served in uh
um after Hurricane Dorian in the Bahamas
2019 you know was a big big one Category
5 stuck over Grand Bahama and [__] for
over 24 hours it stalled there just just
total devastation and that was this
point where I realized like man like I
can do I can do stuff outside the M I
can use my skills to help here right and
that's kind of where we started thinking
about ear recovery but prior to that
there were some things in my life that I
was doing that I didn't even really
recognize like I had been I was a fun
fing alcoholic for about a decade up to
that point through things that I'd seen
best friend being killed you know wife
cheating on me when I was overseas like
all these things that add up and and um
I got to a point where you know I got
back in July I was like man I know what
I'm doing I'm going to go I'm going to
go help people abroad utilize my skills
right wow but I hadn't killed I hadn't
gotten rid of those demons yet and when
I started uh putting my retirement
packet in um you you drop it in you know
I'm at like 19 years at that point I
told him hey this is what I'm going to
do uh I'm I'm going to retire out of the
military and they sf's pretty cool so
they're like well what are you going to
do I'm like I'm going to go help people
they're like all right man you don't
need to come to work just come check in
every once once in a while right wow so
uh in doing that I I went to a I started
my out processing right and uh they took
me to this Clinic it's called Intrepid
spirit and it's great right I I've been
involved in a couple IID blasts and some
of the weaper I trained on I have
traumatic brain injury so they put me in
this room and I have all these doctors
around and neurosurgeons psychologists
all these people right and they go over
my case and and uh they assigned me a
psychiatrist I've never had one before
and this is in you know the coid time
right so this is a zoom call like once
every two weeks so I talked to this lady
and you know you know bless her she's
trying to do her best but I talked to
her and um she's like all right you know
introduces herself and this is a one-
hour call every two weeks and she's like
okay what I want you to do is I want you
to think back
to like a memory or a Time on one of
your deployments that was really tough
and she's like I want you to find one
that like is you've almost forgotten and
I was like all right so I started
digging you know because I I buar this
stuff deep man like you know that's a
like we we got that we got to hide it in
this box and and put inside me that's
what I was doing and I found one of
these memories and and I remember you
know this is another time in Iraq and we
got this this news of this uh Mass grave
like there' been like an ethnic
cleansing and so we're walking around we
walk out there and we find this supposed
site and we start digging it up with our
hands in our little shovels and sure
enough we start unearthing all these
bodies with like I mean we got gloves on
but basically our bare hands you know
I'm seeing like little kids decomposing
faces and hands and I'm like holy hell
you know that's deep that's that's rough
um and I started explaining that to
her and then Bing he's like time's up
shut the F and I was like all right
should she's like we'll talk we'll talk
about this in two
weeks so man so then like everything
starts coming back right like I was
trying to go sober again at that point
start drinking again I got my anxiety I
got nightmares I've got It's All Coming
Back and and I talked to her two weeks
later she's like how you feeling I'm
feeling like [__] you know all
everything like all my symptoms are back
like I I can't stop but every time I
close my eyes I see that and she's like
all right so
she puts me on medication so now I'm on
Zoloft and I start getting on now on all
these prescription medications and
they're trying to help me but I I didn't
have the like tools to process
like it was rough man so I I start I
started taking medication I'm on all
this stuff and and I'm drinking again
I'm I'm lying to my now wife my
girlfriend because I you know I'm trying
to make myself feel better so that's
what alcohol did that for me and um I
get to a point in in December and and I
was at that last straw like I knew what
I wanted to do in life but I still had
those anchors that were holding me back
and then you know like I talk about
anchors a lot when I speak to my B it's
like you know they can be good at some
point they can keep you stable but at
the end of the day you're not going to
get to where you want to go if you keep
them there and um December 5th I go out
and talk to my wife she's off doing
wonderful things as she always is and
she's like you you can be drinking
tonight I like no no no you know I'm
good I I promise you baby I'm not drink
anymore and uh sure enough I get around
my friends and one thing leads another
and I wake up that next morning like
passed out on my phone like completely
wasted all this and and
um I just remember that morning man like
I was like [__] that's it like she's
gone my purpose is gone I'm out of the
military now like I got nothing and I
had we talk about the suicide I had a
plan you know so I was going to execute
that plan that morning and um I always I
have a nightstand my bed so I pull my
Glock 19 out of there and I have all my
stuff set up like I was going to act
like I was cleaning my weapon and uh I
take the weapon down and I I put it here
up against my leg and I was planning on
shooting myself at the femoral and just
letting myself bleed out and I had two
things happen I had bought her this
little this is going to be emotional
about me because she's my dog just died
but I had bought her this uh this great
dane his name is Captain he a little
puppy you know and I didn't close my
door enough so he pushed the door open
and he came and sat down and was looking
at me and I was like I was like man I
can't I can't do this in front of this
dog you know like so I Put the gun down
temporarily and I went and put him in
the bathroom and then I came back from
the bathroom I was like all right uh now
my brain's starting to think a little
bit more rationally I'm like I got a who
can I have come over to check on the dog
who's strong enough to potentially see
me dead so I'm thinking all right well
I'll think about some of my military
buddies right they've seen dead all the
time and I'm like man I can't put that
on them you know and so I'm like how am
I going to do this and I pick up my
phone and I had a message from my now
wife Britney you know and it was it was
like a message of love man it was like
and she's like so ingrained in her
purpose she's like I can't she's like I
got people helping this
world and I don't know if I can be with
you but I can always love you and I
can't maybe I can't be with you but I
can always be there for you you know and
I was like I was like and that's it you
know like I got to change something and
uh so I put the gun
away I pet the dog and that was December
6 2020 man the last time I touched
alcohol and I've been sober since then
and I talked to my wife she's an
entrepreneur and we start sitting we
start planning things sf- wise man I'm
like I'm not the enemy these things that
I'm leaning on this is my enemy right so
I got to put I got to treat him as my
enemy and we started planning all this
out and that's what we do that's why we
have the healed the heroes program cuz
there guys like me you know that we got
so much good to do in this world cuz it
was after that point it was two months
later I was chasing a witch doctor down
for beheading kids in Uganda wow
and I I was almost not even on this
planet anymore man like so it's it's
unbelievable how we can talk ourselves
into what seems what seems crazy and
take the the easy way out but the ripple
effect of everything with God's calling
what we got in this world man we got so
much work to do that's right and we need
to we need to get past our our feelings
and and our demons and we need to go do
that work I'm I I tell my guys I'm like
you know we got these Demons Inside of
you but there's Angels everywhere like
you can't let your Demons Inside you
destroy the angels and those that you
love and so our work ain't over man like
it's just change
[Music]
battlefields
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already bored Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot um that really
brings you into the folks that we've had
on the show really brings you into their
world live chats with me and the folks
that I bring on the show to talk about
their world talk about the issues that
they're dealing with about their
triumphs and their tragedies just go to
patreon slre ones on this website that
you see right there right on the screen
that's right in front of you this whole
idea was um something about building
bridges and and and and bringing people
together and um bringing folks that
often don't get the mic and and giving
the mic to them so the fact that you
guys tune in means the world anyways
again thank you uh be good to each other
out there rock and
roll